this is from The Daily Mail this blew my
mind my friends Donald Trump's lawyer
requested the court case between Trump
and egene Carroll be adjourned
temporarily so that Trump could go to
the funeral of melania's mother and the
judge said
no this has to be one of the most vile
and disgusting things I have seen in a
long time if you want to know how
depraved and evil these people are the
idea that the judge would say to Trump
you can choose to be in court which is
your right or go to the funeral of your
wife's mother you pick absolutely
disgusting and uh he he he said no there
will be denied and he even yelled at uh
uh Trump's lawyer check this out the
ex-president's attorney's plea was
denied by judge Lewis Kaplan in the
tense exchange before the columnist took
the stand to testify in the $10 million
defamation case
ABA fired back initially refusing to sit
down basically what happens is she asks
for a basically an adjournment just for
the day so we can go to the funeral she
told the court Trump had an Unexpected
death in a in our family which only the
Lord can control Haba said it was
insanely prejudicial for Trump to have
to choose between the funeral and
attending court she said quote I'm
asking your honor to have the kindness
my client deserves to be with his family
tomorrow judge Kaplan shot back indeed
the right that he has according to the
Supreme Court of the United States is
the right to be present either in person
or by councel and nobody is stopping him
from doing either the application is
denied I will hear no further argument
on it havea protested saying your honor
but the judge responded I said sit down
Hama did not sit down it said Abba
before but habba judge Kaplan asked her
what else she wanted to ask she said
look at these typos all over the place I
said I don't uh she said quote I don't
like to be spoken to in that way your
honor I am asking your honor to please
refrain to from speaking to me in that
way it's denied sit
down this is I I'll say it again Kaplan
is an evil man he is a disgusting slime
bag these people are evil there's no
question in my mind I I I look at this
kind of stuff we see it every day it's
one thing when you are fighting for
political power and you think you're
right and you're an authoritarian we can
have our political uh arguments
political battles and these things have
happened throughout his through
throughout history but when you see a
judge with a smile on his face Say You
Will not have the opportunity to to go
to the funeral for a dead family member
these people are emotionless vile
scumbags they say all these things about
Trump there's a meme right now uh I
forgot who tweeted it so I I apologize
for not giving credit but they say
they've arrested Trump's supporters they
have put them in solitary confinement
effectively torturing them they have
brought the Pres former president up on
numerous criminal charges falsely
accused him of things he's never done 30
years ago are trying to strip him of his
asset that's in New York have dissolved
his corporations out all while screaming
you're fascists mhm these people are
like Trump Must Be Stopped he's a
fascist he will do so many horrible
things this to this country this woman
egene Carroll I mean the the the
transcript of the court case is
absolutely insane there was one moment
where Trump's lawyer tried to uh called
for a mistrial because egene Carrol
admitted to deleting evidence and the
judge said shut up I don't care I'm
paraphrasing I don't know will pul the
verbatim quote but I'm I'm I'm sorry I
can put all that stuff aside okay if the
judge is biased and saying yes we know
she deleted emails and texts or whatever
but I'm not going to Grant you a
mistrial because he's biased fine he's a
jerk this denial is just like taking a
dump on the floor of what it means to be
a human it's it's it's taking a dump on
like the whole like justice system the
whole idea of of our of our like
government system the like the whole
using government to prosecute or
persecute your political enemies
opponents andad supposed to be like
there's I understand this I understand
someone being like I want power and then
throw trying to throw someone in prison
there there there is no winning argument
here other than the judge wants you to
know that if you are in line with Trump
they will do the most inhumane things
this is just beginning okay
like malice is right they'll they'll
kill your kids like and smile about it
and and think they're doing the right
thing they look at currently the people
that are like in in charge in the
government the people that kind of set
the tone for what is isn't is not
politically correct they hate the people
that are outside of their political
group they and they really want to do
bad things they want to use the
government to oppress them and there's
not two ways about it you look at what
the way they're treating the J j6 people
you know the people that didn't actually
get into fights or whatever they got
hundreds of people they they arrested
and stuff there's not any debate about
it the the real scary thing isn't what
they're doing it's the fact that other
Americans are just allowing it yeah it's
uh ruthless this behavior is ruthless
and I don't normally see that coming
from the judicial system I didn't think
I was going to see that coming from the
judicial system of the United States you
want to you know you got to have you got
to have like uh forgiveness or like at
least like what's the opposite of
ruthlessness compassion like you're
supposed to mix compassion with law at
least on at least feain it I am an
impartial judge but like ruthless you
you should go to the funeral of your
family CU I'm a good guy no he's just
like I'm evil there's definitely a time
and a place to be ruthless but that
overdoing it will make people hate you
and it'll cause a lot of animos don't
care when when people like Kaplan I'm
not saying him personally but people
like him go and say like kill a dog for
fun and then smile about it and want
people to watch they're psychotic
individuals I mean that in a literal
sense this man is a sociopath who wants
everyone to know that he Revels in
causing human misery yeah there's also
no consequences to any of this right
like he could do whatever he wants
there's really no penalties for him on
this front and it's so interesting
because eege Carol's accusations were
really only brought forward because New
York manipulated their law and created
like this exemption for any woman to
come forward or man to to come forward
and make sexual assault accusations do
you know it was like a one-year amnesty
where any any sexual assault that was
beyond the statute of limitations they
would get one year to bring those
charges up and then after that it's too
late it's literally for this and it was
specifically for the well we I think any
sane person can realize they did it
specifically for this but their argument
is like because of the me too era we're
going to do this then she comes out I
think I think it's in my opinion any
reasonable person who hears what she
says will conclude that she is a
crackpot whack job yeah who uh she even
says according to some reports when she
realized her book wasn't selling she
used the opportunity in the story to try
and push the book on various shows she's
the one that said that like women like
to be raped or something like that sex
not that women she said people think
rape is sexy think about the fantasies
and they were like let's go to a
commercial Anderson was like go to
commercial break they never do that for
anyone by the way they just wanted to
keep her credibility going it's like cut
it to Commercial and let's let's not
forget the court case where she accused
Trump had a juror who had watched an
episode of timcast IRL and that was the
basis for an attempt of attempted
dismissal I don't believe he was
dismissed it's been a long time but that
was big news like for some reason like
everyone wrote about it it was like
juror in Trump trial is fan of timcast
IRL or something and I think he said
like he saw an episode or two and I'm
like what that's it shame on him that's
not big fan couple episodes gez watch 30
or 40 of
them yeah but New York City's actually
trying to extend the the the statue of
limitation now so now they they're
trying to give like a two-year
exemptions for women to go file these
complaints and it's crazy because it's
backing up the civil court system now in
New York and no one's stepping in saying
hey this is a little crazy guys anyone
could make an accusation from 30 years
ago and without any evidence come
forward and we just have to believe it
uh ultimately though also they refer to
Carol as a journalist in a lot of these
articles I think that's so comical
because people like me for an example
were conspiracy theorists but this woman
who said at one point that rape is sexy
and who literally her whole Twitter page
at one point was dedicated to bashing
Trump as a journalist now all of a
sudden it's kind of weird what is she
yeah this is uh like I think she was an
actress at one point these stories are
all over the place
the juror who listened to conservative
podcaster timpool here's the AP
journalist juror who listened to
conservative podcaster timpool joined
verdict against Donald Trump they tried
to get him out remove him and he just
went along with it so yeah yeah I'm I'm
sorry like I don't know what you know
the craziest thing to me is when these
like sexual assault claims pop up 30
years later and people get convicted on
it I'm like what evidence do they have
there's DNA evidence like by all means
but evidence of sex is not evidence of
rape yeah yeah you're seeing ped he's
being smacked around with all these
lawsuits now and ultimately I'm okay
with sexual assault like lawsuits coming
about if there was a criminal case that
came first and they were found guilty in
the courtroom but now we're just we're
fast forward and going straight to to
civil and unfortunately it's cuz he he
actually P actually filed well settled
his lawsuit with Cassie his
ex-girlfriend so quickly that three more
I think it's three more accusations
popped up right after that and so now
he's got to battle these three
accusations and there's really I mean
there's very little evidence that you
could bring forward to even prove your
innocence you're ultimately guilty I
think he didn't show up to for the Emmys
or something he was invited to just
because all these ACC so unfortunately
all these people are going to be found
guilty in the public eye even though
they haven't had a criminal trial yeah
the idea of proving yourself innocent is
counterintuitive you're supposed to have
to prove prove the other person guilty
they are innocent yeah yeah isn't it
disgusting but this is the world we're
turning into and everyone's okay with
this actually it's it actually bit one
New York Democrat in the butt uh Chris
CU Andrew Cuomo sorry Andrew Cuomo
actually got a lawsuit filed against him
for sexual harassment by well he
admitted to doing it oh did he he he
made a video showing all the times he
grabbed people and kissed them and said
it's cuz I'm Italian and I'm like so you
admit to kissing people who did not want
to be kissed well okay sir that like
when he got me toed he was like I'm
Italian I kiss every every body he's a
video of me doing it over and over and
over again and we're like so sh theot
that's just admitting you're doing it
yeah you I mean is it because it's a
civil course you don't have to provide
guilt you don't have to prove guilt yes
it's liability not not guilt and what is
liability technically so Trump was never
found to have sexually assaulted this
woman though that's what everyone is
saying he's found to be liable for a
sexual assault what ises that mean it
means he has like liability you you a
debt an something you owe for something
that may or may not have happened yeah
yeah I think any sane person who heard
the story told by egene Carroll would
conclude that she is a crackpot who made
it up it's it's uh she accused Les moas
and Donald Trump of sexually assaulting
her in the mid1 1990s that's what this
is I don't know who this Les moas guy is
I don't know that she even accused him
of sexual assault did she that's what
Wikipedia says I thought she said that
she brought him up like they went to the
B BG was it the bergd or whatever I
don't know whatever the place is called
hotel and they went upstairs and the
story is really remarkable because
because it's like Trump owns the hotel
across the street he's the most famous
guy in New York he comes in here nobody
stops him nobody recognizes him there
were no people in the building for some
reason the changing rooms that were
normally locked for some reason were
open we don't know why and that's where
it took place you know what else is
really crazy about this like serious
seriously it's it's it's what are we
talking about 30 years later and they're
like yeah Trump's liable for this Trump
denies it outright what evidence do you
have any of this ever happened none
think about how crazy it would be if
some guy just dressed up like Donald
Trump did this and then 30 years later
like it was Trump and like what are you
supposed to say no it was the impostor
well like how does this you know what
you know what it's okay maybe this
lady's telling the truth but it wasn't
trump it was just some other tall guy
she thought was Trump because she's a
crackpot I think if it was anyone else I
don't think this would even I don't
think he would have been found to be
liable thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 P.M and become a member over at
timcast.net